c'était la veille de Noël et dans notre
logis tout le monde s'était endormi même
les souris
devant la cheminée les chaussettes
étaient là attendant l'arrivée du bon
fin de Nicolas
vous m'avez fait
tout était différent tous ces enfants
sont devenus des adultes qui ont cessé
de croire je perds mes pouvoirs magiques
alors pour le bien du réveillon de Noël
je prends ma retraite je savais même pas
que tu pouvais la prendre je crois qu'il
faut qu'on voit le reste du monde comme
des gens normaux c'est une liste des
choses que je veux faire je voudrais
parler avec un chauffeur de tocards
je t'avais dit que j'étais différent ici
je suis ton père c'est moi
je vais prendre un rigolo de chez nous
mettez du cacao au lieu du café et aussi
un bonbon à la menthe si vous avez une
des morceaux de cookies et du sucre
comme ça
pour la première fois je m'apprête à
passer Noël avec ma famille
le nouveau père Noël est en train de
détruire l'esprit de Noël quand la
dernière lumière ce sera éteinte ça
pourrait être la fin de Noël tout
simplement je me suis arrêté trop tôt
mais de candidats je dois repartir au
Pôle Nord les lutins disparaissent tous
vous n'avez pas pourquoi tu ne l'as pas
dit tout de suite on y va aussi
tu as vu ça
Noël risque de disparaître c'est un bon
début